welcome
everyone also from my site from our site
um yeah we are really excited to be here
um nikki are you already sharing the
sites ah they're coming in right now
perfect so welcome to our presentation
about
feedback insights um bringing an
unsupervised
model to production let's see
actually i already introduced ourselves
a little bit
but i might just add uh my part to it so
hi
i'm micah fisher i'm a software engineer
at ing
i've worked at ing for the past two
years and
already mentioned mostly
in machine learning projects building
models
but also bringing them to production yes
so
nikki would you like to introduce
yourself yeah hello everyone my name is
uh nikki van omra
and i'm working as a data scientist at
ing
and um yeah the last we're now going to
talk about the last project
we worked on on feedback insights
together with
micah so yeah let's start
yeah let's get started let's look at the
agenda so today
we want to bring three stories to you
and the first one is a bit about our
business case so what was
the problem that we were facing uh with
customer feedback at ing
and the second part will be really about
the model so about the machine learning
part what did we try
uh how did we evaluate our results
because it's
unsupervised and uh last but not least
the engineering part of things so how
did we bring this to production
really well-rounded story so let's
kick it off i would say um yeah so how
do we collect
feedback at ing uh we collect feedback
via all our different channels mobile
but also web
um and uh how you can see here
on the starting at the very left side of
the screenshots
we have a sort of small front-end
component which asks the customer
whether he would like to
uh give feedback about a particular
topic and
uh there's an uh once he interacts with
one of the different emojis
another screen opens and there he can
also explain himself so he can give
open text feedback to us
now moving on to the next slide um
now flipping the coin what do we
as ing colleagues see from the inside
and that is the voice the voice is an
uh feedback application that mostly our
business
colleagues use uh where all the
different surveys and all the different
responses get
collected so um this is a tool
that uh yeah a lot of business
colleagues use to understand the
customer better
but as you can see on the right side of
the
slide marked in red there is really an
overwhelming amount of customer feedback
coming in
to the voice via all sorts of different
surveys that are running
across different channels throughout the
company in different countries
so our product owner came to us
and said we have so much data but we
have no
insight it takes a lot of time to
analyze the
open text answers and we need your help
so here nikki and i come into play as
machine learning experts i would say
where
um we after a lot of
conversations with the users ended up
proposing to build a feedback cloud
and this is something our users really
really liked
um so what is a feedback cloud feedback
cloud is a
very similar to a word cloud where the
bigger the item
uh the more uh text is underneath
so here let's take the example looking
at credit card
there must be a lot of open text so
feedback about
credit card and that item now what is
the difference between a regular word
cloud
and the feedback cloud is that
we provide more context to uh
the text in the word cloud if you take
for
for instance the example in app
that means uh it's not just talking
about
app but there's context around it so the
user now sees in the feedback cloud that
there's
feedback about logging into the app
so it gives you a contextual
knowledge about what is going on that
you then
can further explore and interact with
now it's really important to understand
that once
when we proposed this solution this was
a mock-up
this had no model underneath and we
didn't even try
a model yet so we didn't know how to
build this
but the users loved it and they really
wanted to have it so yeah nikki how did
we build this
yeah thank you micah um so now
we were up with the challenge okay we
promised to build this beautiful thing
um let's try different approaches and
actually build this
model so now explain more about this
journey
so to create clusters of similar
feedback as shown
in the previous step we first start with
pre-processing so when when a feedback
response comes in
we first remove stop words of the
english french
and dutch language as our model needs to
work for different languages
within ing we um get customer
feedback in different languages and
these are the ones supported at the
moment
and we also remove punctuation
the next step is to create a numerical
representation
also called an embedding from our text
data to create these embeddings we
explored several options
this was one of the most i would say
challenging steps in
creating our model so in the next slides
i will explain how we
evaluated how we created the embeddings
and how we evaluated them before
explaining the rest of the pipeline
okay so yeah which models did we try
so now i will explain a bit about the
different algorithms
we tried unfortunately due to the time
constraints i cannot go into
all the details but it will give you a
high le over explanation
so the first model we tried is one of
the most popular models for
creation of numerical representation
from text data
it's a two layer neural networks and
vectors that are close that are more
similar to each other
are closer in the vector space so for
example
king and queen should be closer to each
other than
king and woman and
to create a representation of the entire
feedback response
we calculate the word factors for each
of the words
in the feedback and then take the
average of the different word vectors
then the second model we tried
is dr beck and as the name suggests this
model
model depends heavily on the previous
model but instead of creating word
factors for each word separately and
taking the average afterwards
we create one representation for the
entire feedback response
and this is done by the introduction of
a document id from which we tried to
predict
the words and um yeah we
trained our own uh word effect and dr
drag models on
our own feedback data then
the third model we tried was a bird
model and this stands for
bi-directional encoder representations
from transformer
and it's a model created by google
it reaches state-of-the-art performance
for many nlp tasks like
question answering and we had very high
hopes for this model so i think at
some point we were joking okay how cool
would it be
if we would have a bird model in
production um
yeah so i can say this was our personal
favorite and lastly we
also tried tf idea we consider it good
practice to also
include a more a simpler model to be
able to compare
and yeah what this does it basically
counts all words
and then applies a method called tfidf
which
gives a lower weight to words that occur
more often in the feedback so these are
words like you me
i and uh which makes them less important
well then uh let's find out which model
gave us the best results
but first i will explain yeah so we have
an unsupervised
model so it's not that straightforward
to um yeah evaluate the quality of the
model
so what did we do um we used a framework
based on a framework created by facebook
which is called send even and this
framework evaluates
embeddings on different downstream tasks
we created
tasks specific for our data set and
train a classifier for each of the tasks
with the embedding from
each of the models as input
so the first task is the predict
question task
it includes data with answers from two
questions
so how could int improve its surface and
you're positive about the contact with
ing because
and then we created embeddings from the
answer to this question
and we train a model that should predict
um
this response is giving an answer to
question one
or to question two then the second task
is the semantic match task
we create embeddings for two feedback
response and predict whether they are
have the same meaning or not so for
example
cannot find my yearly overview and
cannot request a scanner
have a different meaning so we should
just
take a zero and great app and a nice
mobile application
mean almost the same thing so it should
predict a one
then in the last task we predict the
topic of a survey
so we ask feedback
after different after a customer
completes a different process
so this can be for example after a
customer applies for mortgage
and specific for business customers or
just generic
survey when you're using the app and um
yeah we create embeddings for feedback
in
these three surveys and then the model
needs to predict okay
to which topic are they related
and then um this is very important our
assumption is
that if a model receives the highest
score on the downstream
task it generates the best embeddings
so what this basically means is that we
believe
that good embeddings contain a lot of
information
and that and then it should mean that
the classifier that
uses the embeddings also gets the higher
score
and we train we use the same uh
classifier
and um process to for each of the
different embeddings
so now uh to the results
yeah so over here you can uh see the
accuracy of each of the tasks
uh for each of the models on the
training and test set
so you can see that bird scores best on
the predict
question task the tfidf actually um
did the best in our case for a semantic
match and the predict survey
so in the end we
chose to use tfidf for our embeddings we
were a little bit sad because we were
really hoping for a bird model
um but in the end it was um
simple easy to explain and
at this point i wanted to highlight
because it's also very important when we
showed users the results of dfidf and
the model would make a mistake
it um users could understand
why so they they didn't mind that much
but if we showed the bird results
and sometimes it was really amazing what
uh
uh the results bird could achieve but
sometimes it clustered weird things
together
and we noticed that users were so over
focusing on errors
and so and and being confused that we
did not feel comfortable to put that in
production
but the good thing about the process we
have now is that easy
to expand to new languages but the
downside is is that it's not based on
meaning
so after tf idf we're left with the ten
thousand by one factor for each feedback
response as our vocabulary is set ten
thousand
then in the next step we reduce the
dimensions
this is to speed up the clustering
afterwards
and reduce it to a 300 times one
we use the truncated svd for this
then we cluster the vectors using
hierarchical clustering
then it's interesting to know that not
every feedback quote needs to be part of
a bigger cluster
because in our data some customers are
just talking about really specific
problems they're having
and um yeah they're just not comparable
to other feedback
and then in the last step we create a
representation for each clusters
so these are basically the words you saw
in the feedback cloud before for example
reykjavik allen and we use some simple
business rules for this so
we count the words in a cluster and most
occurring
words will be part of the representation
after removing the stoppers of course
and then we do a little
okay we do a small uh simple model to
make sure plurals are seen as the same
word so
account and accounts will not both be
part of the representation
well um now i did a lot of talking and
it's time for some real action i would
really like
to show you the real product but
unfortunately that contains uh real
customer feedback data and i
cannot show it to you um so i'm i'm
going to show you a notebook
um but it has feedback from the
app store in it because that is a public
fee
yeah that's public data so
yeah so over here you can see a load uh
app store data and it contains 1070
feedback responses then i will run the
model
yeah and you can see the feedback is
clustered so in this case
most of the feedback about awakening
ipad start
then dark mode app and
notification later push
and i also can create a word cloud from
this
uh data
you see the same data and then the idea
is that
customer journey expert or can um
click on the word cloud and uh
let me see where my mouse is
i can click on it and i can see which
data is in the cluster so for example if
i go to
dark mode i can actually see
which feedback is in um yeah in this
cluster so
good app nice if there would be a dark
mode
uh dark dark mode works well
does not have a dark mode so indeed oh
i think it's a lot of customers are
waiting for these dark modes
you can look into one other one maybe um
notifications later
push
i think uh push notification do not work
push notification did not work fine but
notification do not work
okay so i guess this is a good point to
uh um
uh mention to people working on this uh
feature yeah so this is the way um
um our colleagues would work uh
with our product and uh now let's
uh go back to uh how we actually brought
this
into production
okay thanks nikki i think we have
not too much time left so i'm gonna keep
it brief because i think we want folks
also on
questions so uh yeah now that we saw how
the model
worked in a notebook uh we still had to
bring it to production
so i'm gonna talk you through the whole
um chain of uh requests
from the user perspective so let's start
on the bottom of the slide where we have
the front-end application
the voice we already talked about the
voice
that is the entry point for our product
owners customer journey experts
where they can look into their survey so
once they
enter their survey and the front end
will send a request to the backend
application
and that is basically the the where the
logic is happening for the voice
the back end of the voice uh
and will in that application when once
it receives the request
we'll uh then uh in that request see
what type of data does the user
request to see in the word cloud and
it's usually
uh already predefined on the page once
you enter the survey there's like a
default date which you can also change
later on
so depending on these settings we'll
send a query to the database and we'll
get that data in batch
so let's say the user requests a word
cloud for the past two weeks
on a particular survey we get that data
from the database
on the left side and the api will then
send an additional request to our model
container
though the unsupervised machine learning
model
is running in a docker container on our
private cloud
and we expose the predictions
via an endpoint so an https endpoint
and we can query predictions from the
model by sending
the data in the request and in the
response we'll get the
cluster names in it
then the backend application once it
receives the response from the model
will push it to the front end in the
response of the previous request
and then the front end parses it in a
very nice looking
word cloud um yeah so this is how it
works
um on a very very high level
well we talked a lot about uh good
stories
but also we have some
learning some caveats that we have to
take into consideration uh when bringing
an unsupervised model to production
so basically because in nature it's
unsupervised
we are training a model on request
every time in production what does that
mean
um it has implications on several levels
of our system
so let's start with the database where
we get the data from
uh you can imagine that a batch request
like this has its limits
so let's just say the limit of our
database is
5000 feedback items hypothetical
that means that we can maximum retrieve
in one request
five thousand now there's probably ways
around it maybe we can do several
requests
but at one point you know our api has to
handle
all that data um so there are definitely
limits
the same goes to sending the data to the
model
over https request you can only
send so much data via https because you
have to serialize that data
has to be sent and has to be
deserialized
and so on and so on so that protocol
in itself has limitations um
now and the model itself also has
limitations because you are training in
production
and the more you have to cluster the
longer it will take
so you're risking timeouts because once
your front end doesn't receive a
response from the back end because it's
taking so long
it might time out you don't set that
correctly
and where do you want to set your
threshold so
we realize that for most cases
it will be fine for us but let's say you
have a business user that wants to make
an analysis of the past two years
that's not gonna happen so if he wants
to have these kind of
uh predictions and this kind of uh
feedback clouds he has to reach out to
us and we have to
do this in a separate manner but we
cannot offer that through
the voice itself we have limitations
there
um and also to keep in mind this was our
first mvp
so we went took us
six months until we went from idea to
production
so we really wanted to first generate
business value
before we overthink these kind of things
and build something that is maybe
needed only in one percent of the cases
so this is a bit of the struggles that
we also had
and the difficult decisions that we had
to make
um but all in all i think yeah we're
really happy with it
and our product owner is really happy
with it so i guess that's always good
and i think we're actually pretty good
on time
we have five minutes left for questions
we planned on 10 but let's see
are there any questions yeah um
thanks a lot for the presentation
actually and you guys have so many
questions
uh quite overwhelming i think uh within
the first seven minutes of your
presentation you started having
questions coming in
um of course we can't take all of them
but then if you guys have the time to
engage on discord
uh we will carry some of those questions
over there um
one of the questions we have received
and also we have more questions
outside of this on uh discord so one of
the questions we have received is why
did you choose
for a model instead of a simple
heuristic to group comments
uh for example levenstein distancing and
uh similar ish to this so there's a lot
on the grouping side as well
um so there is like for example i saw
another one like
can did you try making smaller groups
within your larger groups
and what's your take on this whole side
of grouping
yes go ahead
now you go okay um yeah so we did
uh uh play around with uh
different clustering algorithms and um
with
um yeah how large and small the cluster
should be
um we actually also uh
uh gave them the notebook and gave a
little
instruction on fighting to our business
stakeholders so they could
play with uh different um
like the distance threshold so
they determined in the end um how large
the groups
should be and um
yeah so that was really a collaboration
between the
business stakeholders and us and for
this first mvp we decided that there
should be one threshold for
um uh yeah every server and every
request but this is something we can
optimize in the next mvp
right and i think i recognize the person
who asked this question that this is
coming from wendell
uh awesome talking great achievement he
has a question that
how are the dimensions used by tf idea
versus burke taking into account when
evaluating the classifiers using
sentival
sorry how are the dimensions used by
tfidf versus
taking into account when evaluating plus
so basically
um nikki i think we had way more
dimensions using bird right
i could imagine no for bird
it were uh 300 dimensions if
i remember correctly and for the tf idf
plus the truncate the truncated svd
uh it is also 300 by one so i think we
made sure that the dimension were the
same
and we did a uh we run
a um a small hyper
parameter tuning for every uh
classifier incent evol that's also part
of the
sentival framework um we used
right and then i'm going to pick up a
question from discord from vincent
so what he's asking is that there is a
mention few times that you are really
hoping that
burke would be the best but he really
would like to ask
isn't it a huge relief that you can use
something much simpler
very big relief because you know if you
think about
we are already struggling with uh
runtime
or that's a concern of ours you know the
model can take very long to run
if we would have brought birth to
production that would have just been
extremely unrealistic to be honest i
want to see a use case where
they use bird because making predictions
with bird can
really take quite a while
we noticed that during experimentation
so huge relief also explain that to your
product owner you know like it's always
good when you can explain something to
your stakeholders
um why things happen the way they happen
and tf idf's pretty simple to explain i
think
awesome yeah i'll just uh i'll let you
take one of the questions from q
a and then we'll close it up there
this is a nice one nikki vinai is asking
are these multilingual data
sets and if so the embeddings created
were separately made for each language
or combined
i think this is a very interesting uh
one to talk about
yeah so uh indeed we have a
multi-language data set
um and
we run the same model
on yeah on each language
so first we make sure we from each
feedback quote we
remove the english french and uh dutch
stop words
and then we uh yeah we just apply the
the model and we don't make any uh yeah
we don't do anything different for
the different languages so um it could
be that
sometimes english and dutch ends up in
the same cluster if
the english if the languages uses
are using similar words but if the words
are different like awakening and account
um then they will the feedback will end
up in different clusters so
it could be a nice addition to i don't
know first translate the data but
we thought that's nice for mvp too